speaking of Muslims there is a case
documented by Abigail schrer in City
Journal a a devout Muslim had a son
who's autistic and he had a really bad
episode and I think this was during
covid so he took his son to the hospital
they lived in wash in Washington state
and because of the coveted policies he
couldn't stay with his son overnight so
he goes home and the next day he gets a
call from the hospital and they tell the
father well your son's problem is not
that he's autistic and had an episode
it's that he's actually a girl wow and
to this father's credit he played it a
lot cooler than I would have been and
basically
he played along and was like yeah just
what do I do next you know like where
what are the next steps so basically
beginning the process of affirming my my
son's real identity
and the hospital releases his kid and he
takes his family and moves them out of
Washington state because he knew that if
he would have bucked too hard uh social
workers would have gotten involved